imagine if everyone else shared all your
beliefs and opinions everyone thought
more or less the same as you agreed with
you felt the same way about how things
are and should be
we spent so much of our time and effort
trying to convince others of our world
view we invest so much of ourselves into
our world view this is natural and
certainly understandable but what if we
got what we wanted and everyone saw what
we saw and felt what we felt what might
this lead to what would this mean for
everything we value and perhaps require
collectively
the following is a short story where
this is taken to the extreme if you
enjoy speculative or philosophical
fiction stories like this or my short
stories in general I think you'll also
really enjoy my new audiobook millions
of little threads it's one hour long and
only 3.99 it's out now and the link is
in the description
in the galactic planetary network of
Coit there was a planet named sinistral
where everyone shared all the same
beliefs and opinions
inhabitants here fundamentally believed
with absolute certainty that there was
no creator of the universe that there
was no divine order and no inherent
meaning to anything
they believed only an individual
personal meaning that they created for
themselves the government was lenient
all drugs were legal everyone was
allowed in if they wanted laws changed
every 20 years or so which somehow
everyone always agreed on money was used
but not a goal where it was done but not
a focus a large amount of the average
day was spent on Leisure the government
provided Universal social Aid and
everyone was about the same in terms of
wealth and importance or lack thereof
ultimately everyone agreed that economic
growth and needing to work regularly
were bad for both the individual and the
environment there was no conflict no
debating no disagreements and there was
no technological progress no Focus no
Collective higher purpose no reason or
filter for constant change no steady
anchor to Once good things over a
relatively short time unclear
ever-changing social constructs goals
and rules unraveled across the planet
eventually it turned to chaos and Chaos
turned to barrenness a civilization with
no Central structure collapsed in on
itself
there was another planet not too far
away named dextrol we're here too
everyone shared the same beliefs and
opinions as everyone else here however
individuals unequivocally believed that
the Universe was made by and under the
rule of God the government was strict no
laws or rules were allowed to change nor
needed to everyone agreed on everything
and no new people were allowed in money
and work were Central but the government
was completely hands-off when it came to
economic activity and social Aid there
were lots of wealthy people but so so
many more impoverished people there was
no conflict no debating no disagreements
and there was no intellectual or
cultural progress major inequality
oppression and Injustice permeated
across the planet but all inhabitants
agreed that this was natural and fair
and that everyone could reach higher
status with time and effort after not
too long civilization reached a state of
complete and total stagnation and then
collapsed
too rigid of a structure could not Flex
with the wind of time all but a few
Family Lines remained
there was another planet named laxial
where here everyone agreed in complete
unanimity that there was no objective
truth and that everyone's truth was
equally true this quickly posed problems
when some people's truth was that there
was in fact an objective truth there was
no central government no laws no clear
moral code there was complete tolerance
for everyone including those who were
intolerant of others chaos ensued as
soon as the planet's population formed
never allowing it to properly form at
all
there was another planet in a planet 6
where here everyone worshiped logic they
intellectualized everything their Dogma
was science here they lived only
according to data and statistics the
government was run by computer
algorithms they measured good against
evil happiness against suffering
pleasure against pain not too long after
forming this planet agreed that it was
immoral to continue to reproduce
it didn't last much longer after that
a bit further out entering into the
fringes of the coet network there was
another planet named rackendide where
everyone agreed that everything was
energy and vibrations Guided by the
stars and planets in Celestial minerals
inhabitants here practiced Crystal
Alchemy sacred geometry and followed
with the positioning of stars and
celestial objects told them based on
their own interpretations which somehow
they all always agreed on
love was Paramount but not much else
time was spent meditating lovemaking and
consuming substances channeling the
powers of what they referred to as the
one Eternal consciousness
Not much got done though they thought
they were doing everything eventually
starvation and widespread illness
brought the planet to its end
even further out into the fringes there
was another planet named coven where
here all inhabitants believe that the
planetary network was run by an alien
species that used an exploited life
secretly extracting portions of each
planet's resources and Offspring in
order to stay young and Rich Forever all
inhabitants here agreed that this
underworld deep state was at the center
of everything pulling the strings
pushing their agenda and planting false
information and beliefs across the
network no one had ever seen any
evidence of this or any alien underworld
at all but they all knew it was true
their time and effort were spent on
their military shelters and preparations
for the great isolation
they questioned everything except
themselves paranoia ran rampant most
people were alone sometimes what one
fears is what they create for themselves
eventually coven inhabitants began to
believe that their oxygen was being
contaminated with mind control chemicals
by the alien deep State Elites they
avoided breathing as often as possible
the great irony of course was that their
lack of breathing and the filtration
systems and counter chemicals they
created to deal with this issue killed
them all
scattered across the vast planetary
Network where hundreds and hundreds of
more planets like these each planet's
population forming and unifying over the
same beliefs and values and perceptions
further isolating and reinforcing their
own while distancing and degrading
others
at first it was just fundamental
interests and beliefs and personality
traits that attracted people to certain
places then it was all of the subsequent
qualities and systems and experiences
that kept them there the continual
reinforcement and validation of who they
were and what they believed the same
types of products and people and
activities that they liked and were like
ultimately it was never about whether
any planet was right or even good for
anyone but rather whether or not its
people felt good and right
the only way different planets
interacted with each other was through
centralized broadcasts that displayed
across different digital platforms
unique to each planet some far more or
less receptive to outside feeds than
others however even the completely
unfiltered broadcasts were always
consumed in the context of their host
planet and host planet's platform with
those who agreed with the individual
consuming it
eventually most if not all of these
planets devolved into dysfunction at
best and total Extinction at worst
this was the story for almost all except
one planet the planet from which the
entire network had originated from
a planet named Earth
those who stayed grounded on Earth never
fleeing to secluded corners of the
network experience conflict disagreement
and constant unrest but also they
experienced the fruits of this
resolutions intellectual Innovation
technological innovation Temperance
moderation and openness
people who saw the universe differently
who felt things differently who believed
different things became friends Partners
families of course enemies too but
enemies keep their opponents in check
and their own sort of mutually
beneficial relationship instead of
always hoping to create a planet where
everyone agreed and habitants of Earth
worked to coexist and benefit from
working alongside those who did not and
for as long as they did this they
continued to function and survive just
fine the convergence of diverging ideas
and beliefs would continue to work in
opposing Harmony
the planet would remain fragmented
together
[Music]